so which one keeps finally moving out
it's not right abled but this way
there's risotto no mat to show you I'm
gonna prove to you we could all be on
the same page literally okay now I've
labeled my triangle a B C I have this
altitude in here right and it connects
I'll just call this point X right I made
that altitude that perpendicular height
is okay now it's just a bit of a
convention just so we don't get confused
to have likes you how about three angles
labeled in angle a b a c and you'll be a
b c an English see right I want to talk
about the relationship between the
angles and the sides of the opposite
moon right so let's see how this one is
capital a I'm gonna call the side that's
opposite lowercase a okay and this side
this angle is capital B so I'm going to
call the side opposite it lowercase B
okay that would mean if I was following
the pattern but this guy down here
should be I guess we just call a
lowercase C okay
all right now there's one last length we
need this intermediary like that we've
introduced this perpendicular line maybe
altitude since it's a height I'm gonna
call it h5 because I haven't used it yet
cool now we have all these in place I
want to try and use is pair of writing
with triangles because I can do treat in
right angle triangles okay so here's
where I'm gonna start this left-hand
triangle over here I'm just gonna
outline it in red so you can see the one
holding that this what's the name of
this triangle it's um a CX okay in
triangle a CX you notice that it's a
right angle triangle I have a right
angle here which means I have to have a
right angle here you carry that alright
so in this triangle because it's right
angle I can say sine cos tan I can use
my soccer tow business opposite
hypotenuse adjacent all that for reasons
that we come clear in a second I'm going
to say
sine of this angle in the corner sign of
see a X okay right thick big socket are
opposite on hypotenuse what science see
is gonna be equal to based on the length
that I've named it's going to be
opposite over hypotenuse that's H over B
right so I have this okay so that's fine
right now if I have a look at the next
trial over the right hand triangle I can
say well what's that triangle for CHP or
you know what up doesn't it
I'm going to call it bc x the order
doesn't matter but i'm just tend to put
these alphabetical i can do a similar
kind of thing right i think you sine of
this angle over here in the corner on CB
x and i should be able to pull off the
same trick because it's also right angle
right here's the angle which one's the
opposite side its hpk isn't it right and
this is what i'm using sine because i
want to get rid of this H its H Obama
hey and that's the hypotenuse H over hey
okay now look at this right I've got a
pair of equator in this right and they
both have the same actions I want to
make this really obvious so I'm going to
make H the subject of each of these
equations okay so in this top equation I
have to multiply both top and bottom
sorry both left and right by B you see
that so I'm going to end up with B times
this right but just to abbreviate a
little bit see a sorry see a X is just
the same way it's a there's no other
angle that's called a in my diagram I
think so I'm gonna call that sine egg
alright you guys know it usually it's
kind of a bad idea to just call it by
one layer up because it might be a
different there might be different
angular first of that but look in this
particular diagram there's no ambiguity
as to what I can be there's only one
angle where a is a positive in the same
way how would I write a similar equation
for the second one what would H equal
yeah very good
I'm multiplying left and right by a
which gets rid of it or lives in a
minute and pops it over here with the
sign so it's going to become a sign and
B is the heart of that angle now if H is
equal to that top thing and it just also
equal to this bottom thing now these two
should be equal right if they're both H
then these two should be equal to each
other right so therefore that's what I'm
going to say okay I'm gonna say
therefore B sine a equals a sine B okay
now one step away from what we call the
same rule okay to make this nice innit
remember the whole idea was going back
to my book and angle should be paired up
with its opposite side and angle should
be paired up with its opposite side
right now I have the mismatched I've got
the B's and A's together and they're a
Tamizh so I'm gonna rearrange things I'm
gonna divide the left and the right hand
side by I'm gonna divide both sides by
sine a sine B that's what I wanted okay
so let's quickly do that might divide
this by sine a sine B then I'll do this
to the same do the same operation to the
right hand side okay now whole bunch of
these to cancel right what can i can'ts
a little left sign ain't right bam bam
it's gone over here I cancel the sign
late right bam bam it's done okay so now
let's just rewrite this in kind of nice
neat terms right I'll do it in water
under the age vest a over sine a is
equal to B over sine B now I did this
with a pair of triangles I tried with
Ada and a triangle with being it had i
drawn a different altitude i couldn't
draw the altitude off that way or this
way i could have had the triangle with
CNN right so this what we call a
symmetrical result this is also equal to
I could just go through this entire
purchase again which we don't need to do
because it's going to literally look
exactly the same except there will be
seasons today's right and I'm going to
show that these relationships are all
equal to each other right when you
compare a side with the angle opposite
that should be the same as another stuff
another side and the angle opposite and
the last side and angles this right here
is what we call this sign rule right
it's our symbolic trigonometric way of
saying this right big signs go with big
angles okay
if this guy's B then this guy will be
big as well and little sides go with
little angles this one's me somebody
small okay and that's just saying in an
equation what this is saying in what I
said this before when we were doing 3d
tree right they give you diagrams but I
think it's so much to your advantage to
just enjoy yourself up a quick one that
took me all of like you know 10 15
seconds and what I can do now is write
all over it I can show relation just
like drawing on this thing I guess in
this way so this sign rule is about
matching angles with their opposite
sides or science with their opposite
angles so I'm gonna show those
relationships on here right a the side I
want to find out is opposites me3 you
see that and the side I know 12.3 its
opposite that's 35 degree angle there
okay mismatching those opposite angles
and science is often what trips people
up with it so that's why I go to the
effort of drawing over so now that I
know what matches I'm going to write the
side for this triangle right I want to
find a so I'll write that first what's
the angle of today 73 so a or your sign
73 that'll be equal to another side
divided by the sine of its opposite
angle 12 divided by sine 35 okay so this
this is easy this is just Miss made for
our calculator right I'll just rearrange
it before
I drew it I'll put that side 73 on the
right-hand side by the way quick
question
where'd I leave it edited right why is
it now in the numerator I'm not good to
nominate oh why is that because what
what did i do what did i do for me yeah
from this line to this line i multiplied
by I multiplied both sides by sine 73
that got rid of it on the dura mater
but it placed it up here in the
numerator okay this guy just throw I did
you calculated for me someone already
gone in the itself let's go one decimal
place 20.5 can I get some agreement yeah
yes no yes okay now before I sign off on
this and say does it have units mmm nope
okay before I sign off through this and
say yeah I think I have the right answer
does it make sense here's the first
thing I'm gonna say 20.5 is that like in
the same ballpark as this is since here
in the answers yes it is right if I've
gotten something like 2,000 over here
I'll be like yeah I think I think
something's gone wrong we can maybe put
something on my calculator secondly
there's a nut shell but we were
expecting before but big angles ought to
equate to big sides and vice versa is
this more than this and it is right and
it is roughly like roughly twice as long
but this and the angle is roughly twice
as big as this it checks out on top